>>> THE NFL SEASON IS OVER BUT
THE ROAD TO THE NFL DRAFT HAS
JUST BEGUN.
WELCOME TO "DRAFT CRASH COURSE
LIVE" IN THE "BLEACHER REPORT"
APP.
WE'LL BE HERE EVERY THURSDAY AT
1:00 P.M. EASTERN TIME.
I'M CONNEOR ROGERS JOINED BY
LONG-TIME FRIEND, LONG-TIME
COLLEGE FOOTBALL ANALYST,
MICHAEL FELDER.
HOW ARE WE FEELING?
>> FEELING GOOD.
IT'S NICE TO GET BACK TOGETHER
WITH MY BUDDY, CONNOR ROGERS,
DOING HIS THING.
I LOVE IT.
LISTEN, YOU HAVE THE HAIR UP
HERE, I GOT THE HAIR DOWN HERE,
BABY.
>> LOOKING GOOD, MAN.
I CAN'T WAIT TO GET INTO THIS.
TODAY WE HAVE A FUN SHOW
PLANNED.
WE HAVE TO START WITH THE BLUE
CHIP PROSPECTS OF THIS 2022 NFL
DRAFT CLASS.
THE TOP GUYS, THE GUYS THAT CAN
BE FOUNDATION PLAYERS FOR YOUR
FAVORITE TEAM.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP THERE.
WE'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS AS WE
ALWAYS DO LIVE IN THE APP, FILL
IT UP.
THEN WE'LL DO A LITTLE
DIVISIONAL PREVIEW AND START
THIS WEEK, THIS SERIES WITH THE
NFC NORTH.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PACKERS.
THE LIONS WILL DICTATE A LOT OF
THE DRAFT.
WE HAVE THE VIKINGS, THE BEARS.
WE WILL GET TO THAT DOWN THE
ROAD.
FELDER, LET'S WASTE NO TIME.
THE TALKING POINT, THE STARTING
CONVERSATION OF THIS DRAFT IS
THE PASS RUSHERS AND THE GUY
COMING OFF A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
SEASON.
HE WAS ON THE HEISMAN CEREMONY,
AIDAN HUTCHINSON, 2020 LOSES A
LOT OF HIS SEASON DUE TO INJURY.
COMES BACK TO MICHIGAN WHEN HE
COULD HAVE DECLARED AND
DOMINATES OFF THE EDGE.
STAND UP, HAND IN THE DIRT, YOU
NAME IT, NOW HE'S IN THE
CONVERSATION, NOT JUST AS A TOP
FIVE OVERALL PICK BUT
POTENTIALLY NUMBER ONE TO
JACKSONVILLE OR MAYBE EVEN A
LOCK TO THOSE LIONS AT TWO.
FELDER, YOU EVALUATED HIS GROWTH
THROUGHOUT HIS TIME IN THIS
DEFENSE.
HE EXPLODED THIS YEAR.
WHAT DO YOU SEE WITH HUTCHINSON
THAT MAKES HIM A BLUE CHIP
PROSPECT?
>> I THINK GROWTH IS THE KEY
WORD HERE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WAS GOOD, NOW
HE WENT FROM GOOD TO GREAT.
WHEN YOU GO FROM GOOD TO GREAT,
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU SEE -- TO ME, IT'S THE
HANDS.
THOSE HANDS ARE REMARKABLE.
THE HANDS -- HIS ABILITY TO
SWIPE DOWN IS HUGE.
TACKLES WANT TO PUSH TO YOU, YOU
SWIPE THEIR HANDS DOWN.
NOW YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GO EITHER WAY.
HE HAS UNDERRATED SPEED.
HE CAN COME OFF THE BALL AND
MAKE A PLAY.
THE OTHER PART OF IT FOR ME IN
TERMS OF ELEMENTAL WISE WHAT HE
DOES, WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE, THE OTHER PART OF THAT IS
HIS ABILITY TO KIND OF BE
VERSATILE.
HE CAN PLAY HAND DOWN, BUT HE'S
USUALLY A STAND-UP GUY.
HE CAN GO INSIDE OR OUTSIDE AND
BEAT YOU BOTH WAYS.
THE ABILITY TO DO THOSE THINGS,
HAVING THE TOOLBOX, IF YOU WILL,
HAVING A LOT OF TOOLS IN YOUR
TOOLBOX MAKES YOU A MORE
VALUABLE PLAYER.
THAT'S WHY AIDAN HUTCHINSON,
ESPECIALLY AS A GOO WHO HONESTL
WON'T SAY HE WILL GET DAVID
OJABU WILL GET HIM DRAFTED,
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH CLOWNEY GET
OTHER DEFENSIVE GUYS DRAFTED.
I DON'T THINK HUTCHINSON IS A
CLOWNEY, BUT HE'S A WORKER, AN
EARNER, HE WILL GO OUT AND GET
THE JOB DONE BECAUSE HE HAS SO
MANY TOOLS IN HIS TOOLBOX.
HE'S AN ELITE LEVEL HANDYMAN IN
TERMS OF HE'LL SHOW UP AT YOUR
HOUSE, FIX YOUR WINDOW, THEN
YOUR SINK, HE WILL GO OUT THERE
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT IN
FOOTBALL TERMS, HE WILL STOP THE
RUN.
HE'LL GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
HE WILL DISRUPT THE SCREEN GAME.
HE'LL DO ALL THOSE THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT I MEAN BY TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX.
>> I LOVE IT.
I THINK YOU NAILED IT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE GROWTH, HE
SPOKE ABOUT THEY ADOPTED A LOT
OF THE RAVENS PRINCIPLES OF WHAT
THEIR FRONT DOES, IT UNLEASHED
HIM.
I THINK HE'S SO GOOD AT MAKING
TACKLES SET REALLY WIDE WITH HIS
SPEED AND EXPLOSIVE NATURE THAT
IT'S ALLOWED HIM TO DEVELOP A
COUNTER INSIDE MOVE.
HUTCHINSON ONE OF THE HIGH FLOOR
PLAYERS OF THIS DRAFT AND HE
WILL BE TAKEN EARLY.
HIS COUNTERPART, THE GUY WE
HEARD FOR YEARS IS GOING TO BE A
FUTURE NUMBER ONE OVERALL PICK
IN KAEVYVON THIBODEAUX, YOU SEE
THE SPEED AND POWER RIGHT THERE
WITH K.T.
HE IS EXPLOSIVE OFF THE EDGE.
YOU SEE THE LONG ARM MOVE THERE,
THE KHALIL MACK SPECIAL IS WHAT
WE CALL IT.
AND THEN THE GHOST MOVE.
THE ABILITY TO USE SPEED OFF THE
EDGE, TO DIP AND CLIMB INTO THE
POCKET.
FOR THIBODEAUX, HE'S BEEN THE
REEL DEAL SINCE HE STEPPED ON
CAMPUS AT OREGON.
HE'S BEEN A PRODUCTIVE PLAYER.
HE'S GROWN AS A PLAYER FROM
2019, 2020, NOW 2021, A YEAR
WHERE IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS EVEN
PLAYING HURT AT TIMES.
THIBODEAUX PROJECTED AS THE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL GUY.
NOW HUTCHINSON MAYBE HAS
SURPASSED HIM, AT LEAST IN A LOT
OF MOCK DRAFTS.
SEEMS LIKE A NO-BRAINER TOP PICK
AND A FUTURE STUD AS A PASS
RUSHER AT THE NFL LEVEL.
>> WAIT, CONNOR, YOU MEAN A GUY
PLAYING WITH A BRACE ON HIS
ELBOW MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
HURT?
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WATCHING HIM, HE DID EVERYTHING
HE COULD TO TRY TO MAKE OREGON
BE GOOD, RIGHT?
HE DID EVERYTHING HE COULD.
I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO WHAT HE
IS AS A PLAYER IN TERMS OF BEING
A TEAMMATE.
ALSO LOOKING AT HIM, THIS IS A
GUY -- YOU MENTIONED 1920, '12,
I WILL GO 17, 18, HE MADE
OREGON'S CLASS.
HE MADE THEIR RECRUITING CLASS
AT OREGON AND HE'LL BE THE FOCAL
POINT AND CENTERPIECE.
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING TO THE
OFF THE FIELD SIDE OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT I AM THE
FOCAL POINT AND I BETTER
PRODUCE.
HE DID PRODUCE.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT POSITION AND
THE PRESSURE IS ON AND EVERYBODY
IS LOOKING AT YOU, YOU HAVE TO
STAND UP IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
HE HAS THAT ABILITY IN SPADES.
I DIDN'T HAVE TO RUN OFF ALL THE
THINGS.
YOU RATTLED OFF THE LONG ARM,
THE SPEED TO POWER RATIO, THE
ABILITY TO PLAY THAT GHOST, LIKE
NOW YOU SEE ME, NOW YOU DON'T.
HE DID ALL THOSE THINGS.
TO BE -- I THINK ABOUT -- THIS
YEAR WAS UP AND DOWN, UP AND
DOWN.
I THINK ABOUT THE YEAR BEFORE
THIS YEAR, HE WAS A ONE-MAN
WRECKING CREW AGAINST UTAH IN
THE PAC-12 CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
HE GOT TO THE QUARTERBACK,
STOPPED THE RUN, RAN GUYS DOWN
FROM THE BACKSIDE, DID
EVERYTHING.
HE -- I DON'T LIKE TO USE THE
PHRASE HIGHER CEILING WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HUTCHINSON VERSUS
THIBODEAUX, BUT HOW DO YOU PASS
ON HIM?
>> I WON'T.
>> HOW DO YOU PASS ON HIM?
>> YOU DON'T.
THAT'S WHERE I WANT TO TAKE THIS
CONVERSATION BEFORE WE MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT POSITION GROUP.
I'M NOT MOVING HIM FROM THE
NUMBER ONE SPOT.
I THINK HE'S THE BEST OVERALL
PLAYER IN THE DRAFT CLASS.
I THINK HE'S AS GOOD AS AN
ATHLETE AS HUTCHINSON IS, I
THINK THIBODEAUX'S EXPLOSIVENESS
IS IN A DIFFERENT TIER FROM A
REALLY GOOD PASS RUSH CLASS.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
WHEN YOU PULL ALL THREE YEARS
TOGETHER OF TAPE AND YOU KNOW
FROM EVALUATING THESE GUYS AS
RECRUITS, IT'S NOT JUST THE
THREE YEARS, IT'S LIVING UP TO
THAT STATUS AND CARRYING IT OVER
TO OREGON AND WE THINK HE'S
GOING TO CARRY IT OVER TO THE
NFL.
DO YOU THINK HE'S THE BLUE CHIP
GUY OF THIS CLASS?
THE BEST OF THE BEST?
>> YEAH.
I THINK HE'S GOT UNDENIABLE
TRAITS.
WE'LL GET INTO THIS AS WE GET
INTO THE SHOW OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS, HE HAS TRAITS
THAT MATCH HIS PRODUCTION.
OR EXCUSE ME, PRODUCTION THAT
MATCHES HIS TRAITS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT DORIAL
GREEN-BECKUM, HE GOES OUT THERE,
DOES EVERYTHING THE RIGHT WAY,
GETS IT DONE AND MAKES IT
HAPPEN.
THE ONLY REASON YOU PASS ON HIM
IS IF YOU DON'T LIKE HIM IN
INTERVIEWS.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING ELEMENT.
WE HAVE TO ADD THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT -- I CALL IT THE HOLY
TRINITY, WE HAVE FILM, WE HAVE
YOUR MEASURABLES, THE COMBINE,
THEN THIS OTHER ELEMENT WHICH
ARE THE MED CHECKS AND
INTERVIEWS.
THAT IS HOW YOU END UP GETTING
DRAFTED SOMEWHERE.
IF YOU HAVE A FAILURE IN ONE OF
THOSE PARTS, YOU CAN FALL.
WE SAW IT WITH RANDY MOSS.
HAD THE FILM, THE MEASURABLES,
DIDN'T HAVE THE OTHER PART OF
IT.
THAT'S WHY WE SAW RANDY MOSS
FALL, EVEN THOUGH HE'S THE
GREATEST RECEIVER IN MY MIND.
THIBODEAUX HAS THE FILM AND THE
MEASURABLES, WELL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE NEXT STEP.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, WHERE DOES
HE FIT INTO THE PANTHEON OF THE
LAST DECADE OF PASS RUSHERS?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I LIKE TO LOOK AT SOMEONE, LIKE
A BRIAN BURNS.
I THINK HE'S ABOVE THAT.
I LOVED BRIAN BURNS.
I THOUGHT HE WAS A NO-BRAINER
TOP TEN SELECTION, WOULD COME IN
AND BE PRODUCTIVE RIGHT AWAY.
HE HAD A GOOD CAREER WHEN
HEALTHY.
I DON'T THINK HE'S -- LET'S NOT
TRY TO MAKE HIM MYLES GARRETT OR
CHASE YOUNG OR ONE OF THE BOSAS
WHO WERE SPECIAL PLAYERS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT BRIAN
BURNS TIER, EVEN BEING A LITTLE
BETTER THAN WHAT HE WAS, THAT'S
A REALLY SPECIAL PLAYER AT THE
NFL LEVEL IN TERMS OF HOW
PREMIUM EDGE PASS RUSH IS.
I LIKE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP THE
HOLY TRINITY.
WHEN THAT LAST LEG OF THE
TRIPOD, WHAT WE DON'T SEE.
WE DON'T SEE THE MEDICALS OR THE
INTERVIEWS ON TV.
THOSE ARE WHAT TEAMS LIKE TO
KEEP TO THEMSELVES FOR GOOD
REASON.
THAT WILL DICTATE THE CEILING OF
THIBODEAUX.
IF HE'S THE NUMBER ONE OVERALL
PICK OR THE NUMBER FIVE OVERALL
PICK.
LET'S MOVE TO THE OFFENSIVE
LINE.
THIS IS A LOADED GROUP.
THIS HAS AT TACKLE A BIG THREE
FOR ME.
THEN OBVIOUSLY THE ONE CENTER
THAT IS A SPECIAL, SPECIAL
PLAYER.
LET'S START WITH THE BIG THREE.
WE'LL KEEP THIS WITH IKEM EKWONU
FROM N.C. STATE.
HE CAME INTO THE SEASON, SCOUTS
WERE LOOKING AT HIM SAYING HE
HAS SOME ISSUES, HE MIGHT HAVE
TO KICK IN AT GUARD.
HE SILENCED ALL OF THOSE.
HE'S A DOMINANT RUN BLOCKER.
HE'S THE BEST RUN BLOCKER I'VE
SEEN IN A COUPLE YEARS.
THE ONLY THING CLOSE TO HIM IS
BECHTON.
HE HAS SPECIAL HANDS, A
HEAVYWEIGHT FIGHTER TYPE OF
HANDS.
SO EKWONU TO ME, THE TOP TACKLE
IN THIS DRAFT.
A BONAFIED TOP FIVE PICK.
YOU HAVE SEEN THIS GUY GROW OVER
THE YEARS.
THIS YEAR, EVEN FOR HIM,
SURPRISED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE WANT A FIVE-STAR RECRUIT.
WASN'T A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EKWONU, WHAT DO
YOU SEE IN HIS GAME.
>> BUT HE WAS A DWAYNE LEDFORD
GUY, OFFENSIVE LINE COACH FOR
THE FALCONS BEFORE HE WAS A
COORDINATED FOR LOUISVILLE,
BEFORE THAT, HE WAS AT N.C.
STATE.
I LOOK AT THIS AND I SAY, OH, HE
WASN'T A FIVE-STAR RECRUIT, BUT
HE SHOWED TRAITS, HE DEVELOPED,
AND THEN HE STEPPED IT UP.
I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THE RUN
BLOCKING.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE IF HE STICKS
AT LEFT TACKLE.
I THINK AT RIGHT TACKLE IS WHERE
HE MAY END UP.
THERE IS A MEANNESS AND A
NASTINESS TO HIS GAME THAT I
ENJOY.
HE IS A FIGHTER.
I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THE
BOXING THING.
ULTIMATELY WHAT HE DOES IS IF HE
CAN PUT THE PAWS ON YOU, HE'S
GOING TO TRY HIS HARDEST TO GET
YOU ON THE GROUND.
WE SAW HIM WITH THE LITTLE
THROWBACK.
ONCE HE GETS THE HANDS ON YOU,
HE'LL GET YOU ON THE GROUND.
HE'LL OUT-MUSCLE YOU AND WRESTLE
YOU DOWN.
THE PART THAT'S INTERESTING IS
WHAT HIS PASS PROTECTION LOOKS
LIKE AGAINST TRULY ELITE SPEED
GUYS.
THAT'S THE PART WHERE HE IS AND
WHEN WE TALK SAFETIES AND THE
SECONDARY, WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THIS, I THINK HE'S WAY BETTER
GOING FORWARD THAN BACKWARDS.
THAT GIVES ME A LITTLE PAUSE,
EVEN THOUGH HE IS INCREDIBLY
ATHLETIC BECAUSE WHEN YOU SEE
SOMEONE HIS SIZE, GET OUT IN
FRONT AND GO LOOK FOR WORK.
I LOVE A GUY LOOKING FOR WORK.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
I LOVE THAT HE'S COMING OUT OF
N.C. STATE, NORTH CAROLINA AS A
STANDOUT, I LOVE IT, BUT I THINK
THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW MUCH
WILL YOU WANT HIM TO PASS ASSET?
IF YOU'RE WORKING IN MORE OF
THAT RPO SITUATION, EVEN PLAY
ACTION GAME.
IF YOU WORK MORE OF THAT IN, HE
WILL BE MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN
SOME OF THESE OTHER GUYS.
EVEN CHARLES CROSS, WHO I KNOW
WE'LL GET TO.
>> YEAH.
I THINK SO.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
THAT MIGHT PLAY TO HIS FAVOR
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW THE DRAFT
CAN PLAY OUT.
IF THE JAGUARS PASS ON HIM,
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND.
JETS AT FOUR OR GIANTS AT FIVE,
THEY HAVE LEFT TACKLES.
IF THEY LIKE THE PLAYER ENOUGH
AND MOVE HIM TO THE RIGHT SIDE,
THAT MIGHT BENEFIT HIM IN THE
LONG-TERM.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THERE
MIGHT BE A POSITION MOVE BUT
SOMETHING HE CAN HANDLE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMEONE THAT
THEY'RE PROBABLY WILL NOT BE A
POSITION MOVE FOR, EVAN NEAL.
HE PLAYED LEFT TACKLE THIS YEAR,
RIGHT TACKLE BEFORE THAT AND
GUARD BEFORE THAT.
FELDER, EVAN NEAL, EVERYONE
KNOWS THIS GUY, THE SIZE, THE
POWER, THE PROGRAM.
TALK TO ME ABOUT EVAN NEAL.
>> EVAN NEAL, ONE OF THE BEST
OFFENSIVE LINEMEN SINCE HE WAS
IN, LIKE, TENTH GRADE.
IT'S INSANE HOW HE BIG HE IS.
CON
CONNOR, IT'S CRAZY HOW BIG HE
IS.
>> MY GOD, HE'S -- AND HE
CARRIES THE WEIGHT WELL.
THAT'S WHAT'S INSANE.
>> YEAH.
HE'S NOT SLOPPY.
HE'S A BIG GUY THAT MOVES
AROUND.
THE BIG THING FOR ME, THERE'S
TWO THINGS.
ONE, WHEN I WATCH EVAN NEAL,
IT'S A QUESTION OF -- I HATE
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT EFFORT.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF EFFORT.
IT'S AN ISSUE OF KNOWING YOU CAN
WIN.
/
KNOWING YOU CAN WIN VERSUS
WANTING TO DESTROY.
HE KNOWS HE CAN WIN EVERY SNAP,
BUT I WANT HIM TO DO MORE SEEK
AND DESTROY.
THAT WAS UP AND DOWN DEPENDING
ON WHETHER ALABAMA WAS UP AND
DOWN IN GAMES.
AGAINST GEORGIA, HE WAS A
DESTROYER.
IT'S LIKE PLAYING WITH YOUR
FOOD.
YOU PUSH IT AROUND YOUR PLATE
BEFORE YOU TAKE IT ALL DOWN.
I WANT TO SEE HIM EVERY SINGLE
PLAY GO OUT THERE AND BE A HEAT
SEEKING MISSILE SET TO DESTROY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION OF TALENT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION OF ABILITY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION OF STRENGTH
OR SIZE OR ANY OF THOSE THINGS.
HE'S REMARKABLE.
I WANT IT EVERY PLAY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT EFFORT, BECAUSE
HE WINS ALMOST EVERY SINGLE REP.
HE GIVES YOU EFFORT TO WIN EVERY
SINGLE REP.
I WANT TO SEE THAT DESTRUCTION
THAT WE JUST WATCHED WITH
EKWONU.
WHEN A GUY IS 350 POUNDS, CAN
MOVE, LET'S BRING IT.
>> THE TWO THINGS I WROTE DOWN
WITH NEAL, HE'S A BLUE CHIPPER.
THIS IS KNIT PICKING --
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU WANT TO SEE CARNAGE ALL
THE TIME FOR HIS SIZE.
YOU KNOW HE CAN DO IT.
TWO, A LITTLE BIT OF BALANCE AT
THAT SIZE.
THERE'S TIMES WHERE HE WINS THE
REP AND HE'S ON THE GROUND.
YOU WOULD RATHER NOT SEE HIM ON
THE GROUND AS MUCH.
BUT HE CAN GET THERE.
HE CAN CLEAN THAT UP, THE KIND
OF ATHLETE HE IS AT THAT SIZE,
HE'LL BE OKAY.
THAT'S WHY A LITTLE SNEAK PEEK,
I THINK JAVL CKSONVILLE WOULD
PREFER HIM AT TACKLE THAN EKWONU
AT LEFT TACKLE BECAUSE OF THAT
PASS PROTECTION CEILING IN A
SENSE, WHICH IS WELL TAPPED
INTO.
EVEN HAS ROOM TO GROW.
A GUY WITH ALL-WORLD PASS RUSH
CEILING.
TWO-YEAR STARTER AT LEFT TACKLE.
HE CAN ALMOST LULL YOU TO SLEEP
AT TIMES.
THAT'S HOW GOOD HIS FEET ARE.
THIS IS AN ATHLETE.
WE LOOKED AT EKWONU, THE
BRAWLER, WE LOOKED AT NEAL, THE
COMPLETE PACKAGE IN TERMS OF
SIZE.
HE'S THE PROTOTYPE YOU WANT AS
YOUR FRANCHISE CORNERSTONE.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN THE LAST TWO
YEARS AS A STARTER?
>> I THINK HE'S A GUY WHO HAS
BEEN HELPED TREMENDOUSLY.
I THINK HE'S BEEN HELPED
TREMENDOUSLY BY MIKE LEACH BEING
THERE.
WHEN YOU'RE PASS SETTING 60
TIMES IN A GAME, YOU'LL GET GOOD
AT IT OR YOU WON'T BE ON THE
FIELD LONG.
LOOK AT HIS BODY.
HE'S LINE, BUT HE CAN STILL
PUSH.
YOU SEE HIM SIT DOWN IN HIS
HAUNCHES AND MOVE A BIT.
HIS PASS SET, HE'S SO
COMFORTABLE IN IT.
HE IS, AS YOU MENTIONED, AN
ATHLETE.
THIS IS A GUY -- I WOULD LOVE TO
WATCH HIM DUNK A BASKETBALL.
LOVE TO WATCH HIM GET OUT THERE
AND HOOP IT UP.
HE'S LEANER THAN THE OTHER DWGU.
NOBODY WILL BE AS BIG AS EVAN
NEAL.
THE WEIGHT HE CARRY, HE CARRIES
IT A LOT MORE LIKE ONE OF THOSE
BASKETBALL GUYS.
I DO THINK HAVING THE PASS IT AS
FREQUENTLY AS HE HAD TO BECAUSE
OF THE STYLE OF OFFENSE THEY
PLAYED, THAT'S GOING TO HELP IN
TODAY'S NFL.
DOES THAT MEAN HE'LL BE A TOP
FIVE GUY?
MAYBE NOT.
THAT MIGHT HELP HIM, TOO,
BECAUSE HE MIGHT GO TO A TEAM
WITH AN ESTABLISHED QUARTERBACK,
A TEAM THAT WILL THROW THE BALL
A TON AND BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
ESTABLISHED QUARTERBACK AND
YOU'RE DRAFTED EARLY ENOUGH TO
GET HIM BUT YOU'RE ALSO LOSING
GAMES.
HE WILL HAVE TO PASS A LOT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO COME FROM
BEHIND.
THOSE THINGS WORK IN CONCERT TO
PUSH HIM UP AND MEAN MORE.
I LOVE HIS BODY STYLE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU CAN BUILD
AN ENTIRE OFFENSIVE LINE IN HIS
BODY STYLE.
I DO THINK THAT HAVING HIM AS
THE GUY THAT HAS TO TRACK DOWN
CHASE YOUNG, IF YOU'RE IN THE
NFC EAST.
TRACKING DOWN CHASE YOUNG OR
PLAYING AGAINST T.J. WATT, IF
YOU HAVE TO DO THOSE THINGS,
THIS GUY IS GOOD FOR THAT.
HE CAN MOVE.
I THINK THAT'S THE GREATEST
COMPLIMENT TO HIM IS HIS ABILITY
TO MOVE.
IF YOU'RE AN AGGRESSIVE RUN
GAME, HE CAN CHECK A GUY AND
THEN GET TO THE NEXT LEVEL SO
YOUR RUNNING BACK CAN FIND A
CREASE AND MAKE A CUT.
>> YEAH.
FOE CLOSE THE CAP TER OHAPTER O
YOU CAN FIND HIM ON AN ISLAND.
THAT'S A HIGH PRAISE SAYING FOR
ANY TACKLE, TO TRUST HIM ON AN
ISLAND AGAINST TOP TIER PASS
RUSHERS.
THE LAST GUY ON THE OFFENSIVE
LINE WITH THE BLUE CHIP
PROSPECTS, IT'S NOT EASY FOR A
CENTER TO ENTER THIS
CONVERSATION BUT IT'S HAPPENED.
TYLER LINDERBAUM FROM IOWA.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A STATE
CHAMPION WRESTLER.
THAT KINDS OF HANDS AND POWER.
HE'S NOT THE BIGGEST CENTER.
HE'S ABOUT 290 POUNDS.
HE'S EXPLOSIVE.
HE DOES NOT JUST LIKE TO CLIMB
LINEBACKERS, HE LIKES CLIMBING
AND FINISHING HIS BLOCKS.
SCOUTS, COACHES LOVE THAT.
LINDERBAUM IS TAYLOR MADE FOR
THOSE THINGS.
HE HAS AN ADEQUATE ANCHOR AT HIS
SIZE TO HOLD UP AND PASS ON THE
INSIDE AGAINST GUYS MUCH BIGGER
THAN HIM.
AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DOMINANT FOOTBALL PLAYERS WE'VE
SEEN IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL THE
LAST TWO YEARS AT HIS POSITION.
THAT'S YOUR TAKE ON LINDERBAUM?
>> I THINK HE'S REALLY GOOD.
I STRUGGLE FROM A CENTER STAND
POINT BECAUSE I LOVE GARRETT
BRAD BURRBER
BRADBERRY, WE SEE WHERE HE GOES
IN THE DRAFT.
I LOVE CREED HUMPHREY, WE SEE
WHERE HE GOES IN THE DRAFT.
HOW MUCH BETTER IS LINDERBAUM
THAN THOSE TWO GUYS?
RIGHT?
>> SURE.
HE'S SO GOOD.
SUPER SMART.
ONE THING I WILL DO ON THIS SHOW
ALL THE TIME, WHEN I THINK A GUY
IS SUPER SMART, I'LL SAY IT.
THIS GUY IS SUPER SMART, KNOWS
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE WATCHING
HIM GO DEEPER INTO THE
THREE-POINT AND LOOK AROUND,
THIS GUY, HE'S OVER HERE, HE'S
OVER HERE.
HIM OVER HERE.
THEN GET BACK DOWN.
HE'S TEACHING THE QUARTERBACK
ABOUT FOOTBALL BASICALLY.
HE HAD TO TEACH SPENCER PETRUS
ABOUT FOOTBALL SO THEY COULD WIN
FOOTBALL GAMES.
I LIKE HIM.
THERE'S NO DISAGREEMENT WITH ME.
I FIND IT INTERESTING, LIKE, HOW
DO WE -- IT'S SUCH A SLIDING
SCALE YEAR TO YEAR WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT CENTER POSITION.
>> IT REALLY IS.
IT'S A POSITION EVEN IF
LINDERBAUM IS THE BEST THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN YEARS OR EVEN HALF
A DECADE, CLOSE TO A DECADE,
THAT DOES NOT MAKE HIM A LOCK
FOR THE TOP TEN.
I DO NOT THINK LINDERBAUM WILL
GO IN THE TOP TEN OF THIS DRAFT.
HE'S A FANTASTIC PLAYER.
YOU SAID SMART PLAYER.
WE'LL CONTINUE WITH THAT TREND
AND ROLL WITH KYLE HAMILTON.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT SMART AND
RELIABLE ON THE BACK END, A
LEADER FOR NOTRE DAME.
I LOOK AT HAMILTOHAMILTON, IF Y
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR, WHAT
CAN'T YOU ASK THIS GUY TO DO?
IF YOU WANT HIM TO PLAY DOWN IN
THE BOX, HE CAN.
TWO HIGH, SINGLE HIGH, ROME IN
RANGE.
BLITZ, PLAY A SUB PACKAGE
LINEBACKER ROLE COVERING THE
SLOT, KYLE HAMILTON IS THE REAL
DEAL.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS IN
THE DRAFT.
IT'S A LITTLE SIMILAR TO THE
CENTER CONVERSATION I THINK,
FELDER, WHERE I THINK HE'LL GO
BEFORE LINDERBAUM, BUT HOW HIGH
WILL A SAFETY GO?
HOW HIGH CAN HAMILTON GO?
WHY IS HE THIS GREAT?
>> HE'S A TOP THREE OR FOUR
PLAYER IN THIS DRAFT.
IT'S FRUSTRATING THAT SAFETIES
CAN'T GET PICKED THAT HIGH,
ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S NFL.
THEY'RE SOME OF YOUR MOST
IMPORTANT PLAYERS, PICK THEM
HIGHER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GUYS WHO
HAVE TO PROTECT OVER THE TOP,
COME DOWN AGAINST THE RUN, COVER
A SLOT, COVER A TIGHT END.
TIGHT ENDS, WE'LL TALK TIGHT
ENDS LATER.
TIGHT ENDS ARE NOT MET -- WE'RE
SEEING ALL THIS HAPPEN.
FOR ME, I LOVE HIM.
COUPLE OF THE PLAYS HE MADE, I
THINK IT WAS IN THE SYRACUSE
GAME GOING FROM THE FAR HASH TO
THE NEAR SIDELINE.
AND MAKE A PLAY ON THE FOOTBALL.
I'M LIKE YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
IT'S NOT -- IT'S A COMBINATION.
IT'S INTELLIGENCE MIXED WITH
ATHLETICISM BECAUSE HE KNOWS
WHAT THE PLAY IS, HAS TO SHOW
WHAT HE SHOWS, THEN GOES AND
GOES AND TAKES THE BALL AWAY AND
GOES AND BATS THE BALL AWAY.
HE'S ALSO A GOOD TACKLER, WHICH
I DON'T THINK ENOUGH PEOPLE PUT
VALUE ON.
EVERYBODY LOOKS AT PASS
BREAKUPS, INTERCEPTIONS, BIG
HITS, BUT NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE LOOK
AT SOME COMBINATION OF DENIAL
FOOTBALL AND ALSO TACKLING.
TACKLING IS IMPORTANT.
BEING ABLE TO TACKLE A GUY FOR
MINIMAL GAIN IS HYPER CRITICAL.
>> I WOULD ARGUE IT'S AS
IMPORTANT AS EVER WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE DOMINANT OFFENSES IN THE
NFL.
THE GOAL IS TO GET THE BALL IN
THE BEST PLAYER'S HANDS, SCHEME
THE TOUCHES AND LET THEM
MANUFACTURE THE YARDS.
WHEN YOU SEE DEBO SAMUEL, THAT'S
THE FIRST THING YOU THINK OF.
KYLE HAMILTON WILL BRING THAT ON
THE BACK END OR BRING IT UP AS
WELL.
LET'S TAKE THIS IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
A PLAYER YOU AND I STRUGGLE WITH
AS A BLUE CHIP PLAYER BUT HE'S
IN THE SHOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH HIM.
THAT'S DERRICK SINGLY.
HE WAS DOMINANT FOR A
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM.
BALL SKILLS, LENGTH, SPEED.
REALLY THE COMPLETE PACKAGE AT
CORNER WHERE THIS GUY IF HE WAS
IN THE DRAFT, HE WOULD BE A LOCK
TO BE A TOP FIVE PICK.
2020 AND 2001 WHAT WAS RUINED TO
DIFFERENT INJURY.
WHAT DO WE DO WITH DEREK
STINGLEY AT THIS POINT?
HE HAS ALL WORLD UPSIDE.
HE COULD BE IN THAT
CONVERSATION, BUT THE REALITY IS
FROM A RECENT SAMPLE THAT'S NOT
BEEN GOOD ENOUGH IN RECENT
YEARS.
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTION MARKS
TO ANSWER ABOUT HIM BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THOSE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK THE BIG KEY HERE IS
LOOKING AT HIM AND RECOGNIZING
HE HAS NOT PLAYED A TON OF
FOOTBALL.
HIGH PRODUCTION, BUT HAS NOT
PLAYED A TON OF FOOTBALL.
MISSED SOME GAMES IN 2020,
MISSED MORE IN 2021.
I THINK THE KEY IS WATCHING
HIM -- I'M GLAD WE GOT SOME OF
HIS TACKLES ON THERE.
MOST OF WHAT HE'S DOING IS
PLAYING MAN COVERAGE.
WE FIT SOME TACKLES INTO THAT.
HE'S A GUY SUPER PRODUCTIVE.
A GUY THAT -- LISTEN, HE'S GOOD.
HE'S REALLY GOOD.
WE'RE DISCUSSING HIM AS A BLUE
CHIP BECAUSE THE QUESTION IS
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT HIM?
THE QUESTION MARK IS THE
QUESTION MARK.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN HIM PLAY
FOOTBALL BY THE TIME -- SEVEN
MONTHS, EIGHT MONTHS.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHERE HE FITS.
COMING OUT OF HIS FRESHMAN YEAR,
CLEAR CUT, NUMBER ONE OVERALL
CORNER, SUPER BAD ASS READY TO
ROCK AND ROLL GUY.
THEN YOU SEE TEAMS FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO PUSH HIM IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS SO HE CAN'T PICK
THINGS OFF.
THERE WERE TEAMS TRYING TO PLAY
WITH HIS EYES.
I THINK NOT SEEING HIM THIS YEAR
IS CAUSE FOR PAUSE, AND I THINK
THAT THE QUESTION BECOMES WHAT
DOES HE SHOW YOU?
HOW DOES HE MOVE WHEN YOU WATCH
HIM IN YOUR WORKOUTS?
IS HE HEALTHY?
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT.
I LIKE HIM A LOT.
I THINK HE'S FANTASTIC.
I THINK IN THE PANTHEON OF LSU
CORNERS, I DON'T THINK HE'S
PLAYED ENOUGH TO GO INTO THE
PETERSON, CLAYBORN, THAT WORLD.
EVEN GREEDY -- I DON'T THINK
HE'S PLAYED ENOUGH FOOTBALL TO
FIT INTO THAT WORLD EVEN THOUGH
HE'S CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED VERY
SIMILAR TRAITS.
>> YEAH.
IT MAKE ASTON OF SENSE.
YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT
TEAMS WILL PRIORITIZE CORNER AS
A TOP 15 PICK THAT ARE ALSO
RUNNING SUCH MAN-HEAVY SCHEMES?
THE GIANTS HIRE WINK MARTINDALE,
THEY'LL DO THAT.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE THE
RAVENS AT 14, WHICH IS
INTRIGUING, BUT DOES HE MAKE IT
THERE?
LET'S KEEP THAT CONVERSATION
GOING TALKING ABOUT PHYSICAL
MAN-TO-MAN CORNERS, AND SAUCE
GARDNER.
HE TACKLES, HE'LL THROW HANDS ON
YOU AT THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
YOU'RE A FORMER COLLEGE DB, WHY
HAVE YOU FALLEN IN LOVE WITH
SAUCE?
>> TWO THINGS I LOVE.
HE'S A DENIAL CORNER.
THIS GUY IS GETTING THE SACK.
STRIP SACK TO A FUMBLE.
HE'S A MAN CORNER BUT ALSO A
PART OF YOUR BLITZ PACKAGE.
HE'S NOT SOMEONE WHO IS LIKE OH,
I JUST PLAY MAN.
WE WILL NOT SEE DENIAL CLIPS
DURING THIS.
DENIAL CLIPS ARE HORRIBLE TO
SHOW WHEN THE BALL DOESN'T GO TO
HIM.
HE PLAYS DENIAL.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE PRODUCTION
OF A LOT OF OUR DEFENSIVE BACKS.
REMEMBER THAT ONE THAT -- LIKE
WATER
S COVERS TWO-THIRDS OF T
EARTH AND DION -- DON'T EVEN
LOOK OVER THERE.
DON'T LOOK OVER THERE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
DON'T FORCE IT.
HE'S GOING TO TABLE KE IT AWAY
YOU.
THE BIG THING FOR ME WITH SAUCE,
I MEAN, HE'S LEAN AND MEAN.
I DIDN'T REALIZE HE WAS 6'3".
WATCHING HIM, I WAS LIKE IS THIS
GUY 5'10"?
YOU SEE 6'3", I'M LIKE 6'3"?
HE'S LONG AND LEAN.
AGAIN, HE PLAYS BIGGER THAN HE
IS.
HE'S ALSO GOT THIS SLINKY
SMOOTHNESS TO HIS GAME.
NOTHING LOOKS HARD.
EVEN HIM RUNNING AROUND THE
CORNER TO GET -- RUNNING AROUND
THE EDGE OF THE OFFENSIVE LINE
TO GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
YOU CAN SEE HIM IN COVERAGE AND
EVERYTHING.
HE'S A SMOOTH MOVER.
LOVE WATCHING HIM PLAY.
TO ME, I THINK HE'S A TOP CORNER
IN THE DRAFT.
HE CAN PLAY ZONE, BUT I'LL TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW, EVERY TIME
CINCINNATI FLIPPED THE PLAY
COVER TWO OR COVER THREE, I WAS
YELLING AT MY TELEVISION, WHY
ARE YOU DOING THIS?
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO.
TO CLOSE THE BOOK ON SAUCE, HE
WAS SO GOOD THIS YEAR
ELIMINATING HIS SIDE OF THE
FIELD THAT EVERYBODY REALIZED
KOBE BRYANT, HIS TEAMMATE ACROSS
FROM HIM WAS ALSO GOOD.
THE BALL STARTED TO GO HIS WAY
AND EVERYBODY IS LIKE THEY HAVE
TWO NFL CORNERS.
KOBE WILL GO IN THE THIRD ROUND.
I'M WITH YOU, FELDER, SAUCE IS
THE TOP CORNER IN THE CLASS.
TO CLOSE OUT THE BLUE CHIP
PROSPECTS, LET'S LOOK AT THE
GUYS THEY HAVE TO COVER, STARTS
AT WIDE RECEIVERS.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PLAYERS IS
BURKES FROM ARKANSAS.
IT TRANSLATES SO WELL TO THE NFL
GAME.
THE LITTLE THINGS BEYOND THE BIG
THINGS.
WINNING VERTICALLY DOWN THE
FIELD AND MAKING THE SPECTACULAR
CATCH.
SIX FOOT, 230 POUNDS.
I THINK HE'LL RUN A 4.4, WHICH
IS ABSURD AT THAT SIZE.
HE'S SO NASTY AS A RUN BLOCKER.
YOU CAN MOVE HIM ALL AROUND.
MASSIVE HANDS.
HIS HANDS IN THE 93rd
PERCENTILE.
IT SHOWS ON FILM.
THEY CATCH EVERYTHING.
FELDER, I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN A
BIG TREYLON BURKS FAN AS WELL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
PLAYERS IN THE ENTIRE DRAFT.
>> HE'S AWESOME.
HE'S A FOOTBALL PLAYER THEN A
RECEIVER.
I LOVE GUYS WHO ARE FOOTBALL
PLAYERS FIRST.
HE WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES FOR
THAT PLAYER TO WIN.
I WILL BE QUICK HERE, WE HAVE A
LOT OF SHOW TO GET TO, WATCHING
HIM IN THE BUILD UP, I DON'T
KNOW IF HE RUNS A 4.4.
HE MIGHT RUN CLOSER TO A HIGH
4.5.
WHEN HE NEEDS IT, HE CAN PULL A
4.4 OUT OF HIS BACK POCKET.
THAT'S THE ACE THAT MAKES HIM
GREAT IS WATCHING HIM AGAINST
ALABAMA, WATCHING HIM AGAINST
A&M AND OLE MISS, WHEN THEY
NEEDED HIM, HE SHOWED UP.
HE WAS ABLE TO RUN AWAY FROM
GUYS WHO WERE GOING TO RUN
FASTER THAN HIM, HE WAS ABLE TO
RUN AWAY FROM THEM.
>> THAT ALABAMA TAPE IS REAL.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
TREYLON BURKS, TURN ON THAT.
ANOTHER WIDE RECEIVER, GARRETT
WILSON.
TO ME, CALVIN RIDLEY CLONE IN
THIS DRAFT.
THAT'S BECAUSE HE IS SO GOOD AT
THREE PHASES OF WIDE RECEIVER
BEFORE, DURING AND AFTER THE
CATCH.
HE KNOWS HOW TO GET OPEN WITH
HIS ROUTES.
THE CONCENTRATION AT THE CATCH
POINT AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
SOMEONE MISS.
GIVE ME THE LOWDOWN.
>> YEAH.
HE'S JUST GOOD.
THE GUY -- HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE
HE FITS ON THE FIELD.
BUY YOURSELF SPACE, RIGHT?
A LOT OF RECEIVERS FADE TO THE
SIDELINE.
HE STAYS AT THE NUMBERS, GIVES
HIMSELF SPACE.
AFTER THE CATCH, LOOK AT THAT.
I'M NOT AFRAID TO DO THAT.
CONCENTRATION, OKAY.
I CAN MATCH THIS CATCH IN
TRAFFIC AND SECURE THE BALL.
HE DOES ALL THOSE THINGS AND
HERE'S THE ADDED VALUE, WHETHER
IT'S A JET, ORBIT, MOTION.
IF YOU LET HIM GO FULL SPEED
BEFORE HE TOUCHES THE FOOTBALL
BEHIND THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE,
NOT MANY GUYS CAN TRACK HIM.
HE DOES ALL THOSE THINGS THE
RIGHT WAY.
SO SPECIAL.
AGAIN, WE TALKED ABOUT IT WITH
KAYVON THIBODEAUX, WILSON HAS
BEEN A STAR HIS WHOLE LIFE.
HE LIVED UP TO THE BILLING.
HE'S ABLE TO GET THE JOB DONE.
BELONGS ON THE LIST.
>> AND AN ELITE B ROLL FROM OUR
"BLEACHER REPORT" TEAM OF
EDITORS.
MATCHING EVERYONE WE HAD TO SAY
ABOUT GARRETT WILSON.
TO CLOSE OUT THE WIDE RECEIVERS,
HE'S HURT, DO NOT FORGET ABOUT
HIM.
IF HE COULD HAVE RAN AT THE
COMBINE, JAMISON WILLIAMS.
TRANSFERRING FROM THE ROOM
GARRETT WILSON WAS IN AT OHIO
STATE AND DOMINATING AT ALABAMA.
THIS IS THE BIG PLAY VERTICAL
THREAT OF THIS WIDE RECEIVER
CLASS.
YOU'RE TALKING LEGITIMATE 4.3
WHEELS.
HE KNOWS HOW TO WORK OPEN DOWN
THE FIELD, THE STUTTER, THE
STOP.
THIS HAS TO BE A CORNERBACKS
NIGHTMARE.
>> HE'S DEVASTATING AS A PLAYER.
WE SEE THE STRONG HANDS, I LOVE
THAT.
THE KEY FOR ME, HE HAS AN
EXPANDED ROUTE.
THAT MAKES HIM HIGHER VALUE THAN
A COUPLE OTHER WIDE RECEIVERS.
THAT EXPANDED ROUTE TREE.
AT ALABAMA THEY ASKED HIM TO DO
EVERYTHING, NOT JUST RUN FADES
OR STUTTERS OR SLANTS, WE SAW A
LITTLE PIECE OF THAT HOOK.
WE SAW SOME OF THE DIGS.
THE DIG THAT HE SCORES A
TOUCHDOWN ON IN THE S.E.C.
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME, GUESS WHAT,
OR THE DIG, YOU CALL IT AN
OVERROUTE, I DON'T CARE WHICH,
IT'S A TOUCHDOWN FOR HIM.
THE REALITY OF IT IS IS THAT
HE'S GOT AN EXPANSIVE ROUTE
TREE.
HE'S A GOOD ROUTE RUNNER.
CALVIN RIDLEY, WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT GARRETT WILSON.
I THINK WHAT CALVIN RIDLEY
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE THAT I
LIKED WAS THIS DEDICATION AND
THIS FOCUS ON ROUTE RUNNING.
I THINK THAT GOT BETTER AT
ALABAMA, EVEN THOUGH IT WAS GOOD
COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
I THINK JAMISON WILLIAMS ALSO
BRINGS THAT FOCUS ON THE CRAFT
OF WIDE RECEIVER.
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO GO A
LONG WAY FOR HIM BECAUSE, YES,
HE'S FAST, IT'S NOT ALSO JUST
HIM BEING FAST, HE'S GOING TO
SKIM YOU OUT TO GET INSIDE.
HE WILL DO A LOT OF LITTLE
THINGS.
YOU CAN CALL ANY ROUTE IN THE
BOOK, HE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
HE UNDERSTANDS SPACING AS WELL
AS ANY RECEIVER IN THIS DRAFT.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE FINAL BLUE CHIP
PROSPECTS WE HAVE.
THE FIRST ONE FROM JOE JOE WHO
ASKS US, DO YOU THINK HUTCHISON
IS A LOCK TO GO NUMBER ONE OR
ARE YOU LOOKING ELSEWHERE?
FELDER, I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
LOCK.
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW JACKSONVILLE
WILL LOOK AT TACKLE AND EVAN
NEAL IS THAT PROTOTYPE AS FORMER
NUMBER ONE PICKS WE'VE SEEN IN
THE PAST.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HUTCHISON AS A POTENTIAL NUMBER
ONE PICK?
>> I THINK HE'LL BE IN THE TOP
FIVE.
I DON'T THINK HE'S NUMBER ONE.
THERE WILL BE A DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR OR A DEFENSIVE LINE
COACH THAT IS POUNDING THE TABLE
FOR THIBODEAUX BECAUSE OF WHAT
HE'S ABLE TO DO.
I DON'T THINK HE'S A LOCK TO GO
NUMBER ONE.
THE QUESTION BECOMES WHAT DO
THEY WANT?
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE A
QUARTERBACK THEY LOVE.
IS IT ABOUT PROTECTING THAT
QUARTERBACK FROM LEGITIMATE --
FROM A LITERAL STANDPOINT FROM
AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN OR IS IT
ABOUT PROTECTING HIM AS WE
MENTIONED BEFORE BY GIVING HIM A
SHORT FLOOR, A DEFENSE THAT CAN
STAND UP TO THE OTHER TEAM?
>> ALL RIGHT.
ONE MORE -- ANOTHER QUESTION
HERE FROM B. DOUGLAS SIX WHO
SAYS HOW MUCH WILL THE COMBINE
AFFECT THESE BLUE CHIP
PROSPECTS?
I'LL START WITH THE PLAYER WE
TALKED ABOUT.
AIDAN HUTCHISON.
THAT ARM LEN WILL COME IN.
I DON'T THINK IT HAS THE IMPACT
THAT TRADITIONALLY WE'LL SEE,
BUT IT GOES BACK TO FELDER'S
POINT, IS THERE A COACH OR A
SCOUT IN THE ROOM WHO SAYS LOOK
AT K.T., I DON'T HAVE THOSE
WORRIES ABOUT MEASUREMENTS.
WE LIKE HUTCHINSON, I WOULD
RATHER SHOOT FOR THE STARS WITH
K.T.
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HUTCHINSON, YOU WILL SEE ARM
LENGTH COME UP.
FELDER, WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THESE WIDE RECEIVERS RUNNING
WELL OR NOT RUNNING WELL.
ANY OF THESE BLUE CHIP PROSPECTS
THAT THERE'S A LINGERING
QUESTION WITH THE COMBINE OR IT
COULD BE A GOOD THING?
>> WE ALREADY HIT ON JAMISON
WILLIAMS AND THE INJURIES.
THAT'S DONE.
I THINK THAT BURKS, WHAT HE RUNS
WILL BE INTERESTING.
I THINK -- I EXPECT HIM TO RUN
AT A 4.5, IF HE'S ABLE TO GET TO
WHERE YOU THINK HE CAN BE IN
THAT 4.4 ZONE, THAT IS VALUE
ADDED TO HIM AS A PROSPECT.
THAT MAKES HIM EVEN MORE OF A
TRUE BLUE CHIP PROSPECT.
>> WELL, FELDER, EASY TRANSITION
THERE.
THIS ONE FROM JOHNNY GIBSON,
COULD YOU SEE BURKS BEING THE
FIRST WIDE RECEIVER OFF THE
BOARD?
YES.
THIS IS A FLAVOR DRAFT HERE.
YOU HAVE TREYLON BURKS, 6'2"
225, 230, OR WILL HE SHED SOME
POUNDS TO GET TO THAT 4.4?
IF SOMEONE IS LOOKING FOR SIZE
AND SPEED, ARE THEY GOING FOR
BURKS?
ARE THEY LOOKING FOR POLISH AND
ROUTE RUNNING?
WILL THEY GO FOR GARRETT WILSON?
WILL SOMEBODY BE PATIENT AND
TAKE JAMISON WILLIAMS?
WE DID NOT EVEN TALK ABOUT DRAKE
LONDON TODAY.
THESE WIDE RECEIVERS, IT'S UP IN
THE AIR WHO GOES FIRST.
>> YEAH.
I THINK BURKS CAN GO FIRST.
IF YOU WANT A BIG DUDE THAT WILL
MAKE PLAYS, HE'S YOUR GUY.
WE DIDN'T TALK OJABO, LONDON.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW THIS SHAKES OUT.
HE CAN BE THE FIRST RECEIVER OFF
THE BOARD, THOUGH IF HE'S THE
FIRST RECEIVER OFF THE BOARD,
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
DRAFT?
I DON'T THINK HE'LL BE IN THE
TOP TEN.
IF HE'S THE FIRST RECEIVER OFF
THE BOARD AFTER 10, 11, 12, 13,
WHAT ELSE ARE WE SEEING GET
PICKED IN THAT SPACE?
>> YEAH.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THE WIDE RECEIVER CONVERSATION
AT THE EARLIEST WILL START WITH
THE FALCONS AT 8 OR JETS 10.
IT WILL GET REALLY CRAZY BEYOND
THAT IN ROUND ONE.
LET'S ROUND OUT THE BLUE CHIP
PROSPECTS.
YOU AND I BROUGHT SOME TO THE
TABLE THAT WE DIDN'T UNIFY ON.
YOU HAVE THREE GUYS FROM THE
SAME PROGRAM.
LET'S HEAR ABOUT THEM.
>> LISTEN, I'M NOT A GEORGIA
HOMER OR A GEORGIA FAN, I WANTED
TO PUT ALL THESE GUYS ON THE
LIST SO WE CAN GET THIS OUT OF
THE WAY AS WE GET GOING WITH THE
SHOW.
THE BIG THING FOR ME, I --
THERE'S A LOT OF GEORGIA GUYS
WHO WILL GET PICKED IN THE FIRST
TWO DAYS OF THIS DRAFT.
I START WITH JAMAREE SAWYER.
HE'S THE REASON THEY WON THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
WHEN THEY MOVED HIM INTO THE
RIGHT GUARD SPOT AND LET HIM
MOVE BODIES, THAT WAS AMAZING.
I THINK HE WAS SO GOOD AT WHAT
HE WAS ABLE TO DO.
I LOOK AT HIM AND HE CAN MOVE
AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
THE FIRST TIME I SAW HIM WAS IN
ATLANTA, I THINK IN 2016 OR
2017.
HE LOOKED LIKE A NINJA TURTLE.
HOW THE TURTLE'S HEAD GOES INTO
THE SHELLS?
THAT WAS HIS WHOLE BODY, THE
SHELL.
HE WAS IN THERE, A LITTLE HEAD
ON THERE.
FOR ME, I HAVE TO GO TO JAMAREE
SALYER FIRST.
>> I LOVE HEARING THAT NAME.
HE'S ONE OF TWO PLAYERS THAT HAS
PLAYED ALL FIVE SPOTS ON THE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
THAT'S REMARKABLE.
BEFORE YOU MOVE ON, I DO WANT TO
ASK YOU, WE'VE SEEN SALYER PUT
OUT GOOD FILM AT LEFT TACKLE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM PUT OUT REALLY
GOOD FILM AT GUARD.
WHERE DO YOU THINK HIS LONG-TERM
HOME IS IN THE NFL?
>> MAN, I KNEW YOU WOULD ASK ME
THIS.
I THINK SOMEBODY WILL TRY TO PUT
HIM AT LEFT TACKLE OR RIGHT
TACKLE FIRST BUT I THINK HIS
LONG-TERM HOME IS AT GUARD.
HE BRINGS THIS NASTINESS AND YOU
HAVE THAT TWO-WAY GO.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
THE BEST TRAIT HE WHAT IS HIS
AGGRESSION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MOVING ON.
WHO ELSE DO YOU LIKE ON THIS
GEORGIA ROSTER? DEAN.
WATCHING SOME OF THE THINGS HE
WAS ABLE TO DO OVER THE COURSE
OF THE SEASON, THE LAST FEW
SEASONS, WATCHING HIM IN THE
MICHIGAN GAME, WATCHING HIM
AGAINST ALABAMA AND CALL OUT
MOTIONS AND BE THE FIRST GUY
THERE WAS REMARKABLE.
THIS GUY IS SMART.
I'LL PUT IT THIS WAY, IF PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT DEAN AND THE FIRST
THING THEY MENTION IS HIS
ATHLETICISM AND NOT HIS
INTELLIGENCE, THEY'RE NOT DOING
HIM FAVORS.
THIS GUY IS SO SMART.
HE MAKES PLAYS BECAUSE HE'S
SMART.
HE GETS THIS INTERCEPTION
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THE PLAY THAT
WILL HAPPEN BECAUSE THAT
QUARTERBACK IS A FRESHMAN AND HE
ONLY RAN TEN PLAYS.
I WATCH FILM, DOG.
LET'S GO!
HE'S GOT GREAT ATHLETICISM TO GO
WITH THAT INTELLIGENCE.
SO SMART.
NICKNAMED CODEINE BECAUSE HE
PUTS GUYS TO SLEEP.
>> THE LEADER OF THAT FRONT
RIGHT THERE.
I LOVE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP IT'S
NOT JUST THE ATHLETICISM BUT HE
KNOWS WHERE TO BE.
HE KNOWS HOW TO UTILIZE THAT AND
CAPITALIZE ON.
HIS ABILITY TO BE WHERE THE
FOOTBALL IS GOING, SOMETIMES
BEFORE THE QUARTERBACK IS READY
TO AIM THERE, ABLE TO SNIFF OUT
SCREENS.
EVERYBODY RUNS A LOT OF WIDE
SCHEMES.
TO CLOSE OUT THE GEORGIA
CONVERSATION, WHO IS YOUR LAST
BLUE CHIP PROSPECT?
>> THIS IS A QUESTION MARK.
IT'S GEORGE GULL DULCICH?
HE WAS A FIVE STAR KID COMING
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
WHEN YOU COMBINE THE INJURY WITH
THE LACK OF PRODUCTION IN GAMES
THAT HE WAS IN, THROUGH NO FAULT
OF HIS OWN, MIND YOU.
YOU CAN SEE HERE -- HE CAN MAKE
AMAZING PLAYS.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, WHERE DO
YOU SLOT HIM AS A GUY WHO WE
KNOW CAN DO THINGS LIKE THIS,
BUT HAS BEEN HURT, BUT ALSO
SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN UNDERUSED.
>> HE'S A TOUGH ONE.
FOR ME, HE'S A ROUND TWO PLAYER.
WHAT HE CAN AND CAN'T DO AT THE
COMBINE WILL ABSOLUTELY HELP OR
HURT HIM.
WE KNOW THE SIZE.
WE KNOW THE BALL SKILLS.
SOME OF THE TENACITY ON FILM AS
A RUN BLOCKER.
THIS GUY SHOWS UP TO THE GAME
LIKE IT'S A STREET FIGHT.
I LOVE THAT OUT OF A WIDE
RECEIVER.
HOW MUCH DO YOU PENALIZE HIM FOR
THE LACK OF USAGE AT GEORGIA?
THE INJURIES ARE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION.
WE WON'T SEE THE MEDICALS OR HOW
TEAMS WILL EVALUATE THAT.
HE'S A PROJECTION PICK.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS.
DO YOU PROJECT HIM TO BE MORE
VALUABLE AND MORE PRODUCTIVE IN
YOUR OFFENSE?
I THINK MULTIPLE NFL TEAMS WILL
LOOK AT THAT SIZE AND DOWNFIELD
PR
PROFILE AND THE ENERGY HE BRINGS
TO THE FIELD AND THEY WILL
PROJECT A BETTER NFL CAREER FOR
HIM.
>> I AGREE.
THAT'S THE KEY.
I WANT TO GET TO YOUR GUYS WHO
WHO ARE YOUR GUYS THAT YOU HAVE
AS BLUE CHIP GUYS.
I'VE ALREADY SEEN THE LIST.
I WANT TO HEAR THE COUPLE GUYS
YOU GOT.
>> THIS FISRST ONE EVEN SURPRISD
ME.
JERMAINE JOHNSON FROM FLORIDA
STATE.
THERE'S A MUCH LONGER ROAD THAN
FLORIDA STATE.
THE WHOLE LAST CHANCE STORY TO
GEORGIA, THEN TO FLORIDA STATE
WHERE HE ROUNDED OUT HIS GAME AS
A PASS RUSHER AND THEN GOES TO
THE SENIOR BOWL AND IS
UNBLOCKIBLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT MORE HE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE HIS STOCK.
HE'S GOING IN THE TOP 15 OF THIS
BLOCK.
YOU CAN PUT HIM ON THE FIELD AT
THE NFL LEVEL RIGHT AWAY ON
FIRST DOWN, SECOND DOWN.
THEN YOU GET TO THIRD DOWNS, YOU
SAY PIN YOUR EARS BACK AND GO.
I'VE SEEN HIM WIN THE CORNER.
I'VE SEEN HIM WIN BY PUTTING
HANDS IN THE TACKLE'S CHEST AND
PUSHING ON THE POCKET.
JERMAINE JOHNSON, FELDER, WHAT A
STORY THIS YEAR.
>> HE'S A STUD.
YOU MENTIONED THE LONG ROAD TO
GET THERE.
THAT BULL RUSH IS NICE.
WHEN HE WANTS TO GET MEAN,
ESPECIALLY -- HE'S LIKE A SHARK,
RIGHT?
WHEN THERE'S BLOOD IN THE WATER,
HE GOES.
GETTING THOSE HANDS ON THEM AND
THAT BULL RUSH, HE'S LIKE I'M
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
THEN HE'S GOING TO THINK I'M
DOING IT AGAIN, I'LL SWIPE HANDS
AND GO OUTSIDE AND MAKE A PLAY.
I LOVE THAT ONE.
THAT'S A GREAT PICK.
>> THE LAST BLUE CHIPPER FOR ME
TO THROW INTO THE CONVERSATION,
DEVON LLOYD FROM UTAH.
THE CAPTAIN IN THE FRONT OF THAT
DEFENSE.
REALLY THE TRUE DEFINITION OF
THREE-DOWN PLAYER.
HE CAN PLAY SO FAST COMING
DOWNHILL AS A BLITZER OR RUN
DEFENDER.
YOU SEE SOME BALL SKILLS, THE
ABILITY TO RUN AND COVER.
A TRUE ATHLETE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE FIELD.
I THINK HE CAN PLAY ON THE WEAK
SIDE, THERE'S NOT MUCH HE CAN'T
DO.
A SCHEME-PROOF PLAYER BECAUSE OF
HOW MUCH HAS BEEN ASKED OF HIM
AT UTAH.
DEVIN LLOYD, A GREAT SEASON AND
HE CAN CREATE TURNOVERS.
WHEN YOU DRAFT LINEBACKERS IN
THE FIRST ROUND, YOU HAVE TO ASK
ARE THEY SOUND AGAINST THE RUN?
CAN THEY COVER?
THREE, CAN THEY MAKE GAME
CHANGING PLAYS FOR OUR DEFENSE?
IF THEY CAN'T, WE CAN FIND SOME
COMBINATION OF THAT IN ROUNDS
TWO, THREE AND ON.
DEVIN LLOYD CHECKS EVERY BOX.
>> I LOVE HIM.
HE'S SO FUN TO WATCH.
ESPECIALLY IN THAT UTAH FRONT.
I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED PLAYING
MULTIPLE POSITIONS.
EVEN IF YOU WANT TO FLIP IT TO
PLAYING IN A 3-4 VERSUS A 4-3.
UTAH WAS SO MULTIPLE
DEFENSIVELY.
THEY HAVE AN EXPANSIVE BLITZ
PACKAGE, BUT THEY ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF GREEN DOGS.
HE GOT PLAYS ON THE QUARTERBACK
WHICH ARE GREEN DOGS, WHICH ARE
NOT BLITZES, BUT IF THE RUNNING
BACK BLOCKS, YOU ADD YOURSELF TO
THE FIT.
YEAH.
HE'S A PLAYER.
DID NOT THINK ABOUT HIM AS A
BLUE CHIP, I THINK HE SHOULD BE
ONE OF THOSE DAY ONE GUYS.
IF YOU NEED SOMEBODY THAT WILL
BE STOUT THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
YOUR DEFENSE OR EVEN IF YOU JUST
NEED A TACKLING MACHINE, HE CAN
BE THAT GUY.
>> LET'S LOOK AT TWO COMMENTS
BEFORE MOVING ON TO THE NFC
NORTH.
IS GEORGE DAVIS WORTH A FIRST
ROUND PICK?
I KNOW NOSE TACKLES CAN BE
UNDERVALUED.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING ONE TO
ME.
HE'S GREAT WHEN HE'S ON THE
FIELD BUT HE'S NOT AN EVERY-DOWN
PLAYER.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT PASS RUSH
LIGHT COME ON.
YOU CAN'T MOVE HIM.
YOU CAN'T MOVE HIM AGAINST THE
RUN.
THAT TO ME TRADITIONALLY IS NOT
A FIRST ROUND PICK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I TEND TO AGREE WITH YOU.
OVER THE COURSE OF THAT FINAL
S.E.C. CHAMPIONSHIP GAME, KIND
OF THE BACK HALF OF THE SEASON
WHEN PEOPLE WERE GIVING HIM A
BUNCH OF LOVE SAYING HE SHOULD
BE THE HEISMAN GUY, ARE YOU NOT
WATCHING DEAN?
HE'S NOT EVEN ON THE FIELD.
THIS GUY PLAYS UNDER 50% OF THE
SNAPS.
THE WAY ALABAMA EXPOSED HIM IN
THE S.E.C. CHAMPIONSHIP GAME,
THAT WAS A KNOCK.
I WILL SAY THIS, THOUGH, HE
BOUNCED BACK IN THE MICHIGAN
GAME AND IN THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME IN A WAY THAT
WAS REMARKABLE TO SHOW THAT HE
WANTED TO BE ON THE FIELD.
HE WANTED TO SHOW HE COULD DO
THE JOB.
AND THE ATTITUDE FOR ME -- I
DON'T THINK HE'LL BE A TOP 15,
TOP 20, BUT IF HE FITS FOR YOU,
HE IS SHOWING YOU ALREADY HE'S
GOT THE ATTITUDE AND THE ABILITY
TO DO IT, MAYBE AT THE END OF
THE FIRST ROUND.
BUT I'M PROBABLY WITH YOU,
PROBABLY A DAY TWO GUY.
HONESTLY, I WOULD PROBABLY TAKE
DeVONTE WYATT OVER HIM.
A GUY WHO HAS SHOWN ME A TON OF
WANT TO, KNOW HOW AND ABILITY TO
GET THE THINGS DONE.
I THINK THE REALITY IS HE CAN BE
A PROBLEM FOR YOU WHEN YOU GET
INTO PERSONNEL PACKAGES WHERE
THEY CAN SCHEME TO GET HIM IN
THE GAME.
THEY CAN RUN OUT 12-PERSONNEL TO
GET HIM INTO THE FOOTBALL GAME.
ONCE HE'S IN THE GAME, NO SUBS,
GUESS WHAT?
OUR TIGHT END CAN PLAY WIDE
RECEIVER, TOO, NOW YOU HAVE TO
STAY IN THE GAME WHICH IS WHAT
ALABAMA DID IN THE S.E.C.
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
>> IT WILL BE A HUGE QUESTION
AROUND HIM.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP DeVONTE
WYATT WHO IS MORE OF A COMPLETE
PLAYER.
ONE MORE QUESTION, DO YOU THINK
A QUARTERBACK WILL BE DRAFTED IN
THE FIRST ROUND?
I'LL RATTLE OFF THREE NAMES.
I THINK PICKET, MALIK WILLIS AND
MATT CORRAL GO IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
THE FRINGE GUY BEING RITTER AND
HOW
HOWELL.
>> SOMEBODY HAS TO PICK THEM.
I'M SURE YOU CAN SENSE THE
ENTHUSIASM.
SOMEBODY HAS TO PICK THEM.
SOMEBODY HAS TO PICK
QUARTERBACKS.
IN THE REAL WORLD, THERE WOULD
BE A GK PQUARTERBACK PICKED IN
FIRST ROUND.
BUT THEY'RE PARCHED, SO THIRSTY
FOR A QUARTERBACK.
IF SOMEBODY -- THOSE THREE, I
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO SEE ALL
FIVE GO IN THE FIRST ROUND.
I DON'T KNOW IF GMs CAN HOLD
THEIR WATER OR HELP THEMSELVES.
>> I'M WITH FELDER.
I THINK THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE.
I THINK THAT WILL HELP A LOT OF
OTHER TEAMS THAT DO NOT NEED A
QUARTERBACK.
THEY'LL CAPITALIZE ON THE TOP
PLAYERS WHO WILL FALL TO ROUND
TWO.
THE MUCH HYPED AND PROMISED
DIVISIONAL BREAKDOWN OF THE NFC
NORTH.
STARTING WITH THE DETROIT LIONS.
THE TEAM NEEDS UP HERE.
THE DETROIT LIONS WHO CONTROL A
LOT OF THIS DRAFT.
WE THINK AIDAN HUTCHINSON AT TWO
IS IN THE MIX.
WE WANT TO BRING YOU MORE THAN
JUST THE TOP TEN, THE FIRST
ROUND, FELDER AND I ARE HERE TO
EDUCATE YOU ON ROUNDS ONE
THROUGH SEVEN EVEN FOR UNDRAFTED
GUYS.
THE WHY ONLIONS ARE ON THE BOAR.
WHO DO YOU SEE FOR THEM IN ROUND
TWO?
>> DAVID BELL, PURDUE.
AGGRESSIVE.
STRONG TO THE FOOTBALL.
GREAT ROUTE RUNNING.
CREATES HIS OWN SPACE.
I LOVE ALL THOSE LITTLE THINGS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS GOOD.
HE'S TOUGH, WILLING TO TAKE A
HIT.
I THINK DAVID BELL FITS INTO THE
MIX.
REMINDS ME OF D.J. MOORE WHO
CAME OUT OF MARYLAND AND ENDED
UP WITH THE PANTHERS.
STRONG AT THE POINT OF CONTACT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM THERE PLAYING
THROUGH CONTACT.
FORCING GUYS OFF OF HIM.
MAKING HIMSELF HARD TO TACKLE.
I'M GOING DAVID BELL.
I GO BELL AT 34th PICK.
WHO ARE YOU PICKING?
>> I LOVE THAT SELECTION.
DAVID BELL, A GREAT CONTESTED
CATCH THREAT.
THEY HIT A HOME RUN LATER ON
WITH AMMAN ST. BROWN.
I'M LOOKING AT SCOTT MOORE FROM
WESTERN MICHIGAN.
HE GETS TO STAY IN MICHIGAN, BUT
THAT'S NOT THE REASON FOR THE
PICK.
EXPLOSIVE PLAYS IS WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE OUT OF THIS
LIONS TEAM.
THAT'S WHAT MOORE CAN BRING.
THE ABILITY TO CATCH THE BALL
AND GET UP THE FIELD.
24 AT WIDE RECEIVER.
I LIKE HIS ABILITY TO CREATE
YARDS AND STRETCH THE FIELD
VERTICALLY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
GUY OUT THERE.
HE MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BE THE
STRAIGHT LINE SPEEDSTER, NOT
LIKE A JAMEIS WILLIAMS IS IN THE
FIRST ROUND, BUT HE CAN DO
ENOUGH.
THAT WILL OPEN UP THE RUNNING
GAME AND GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO
IF NOT THROW DOWN THE FIELD AT
LEAST POSE THE THREAT TO THROW
DOWN THE FIELD.
YOU HAVE BELL, I HAD MOORE,
DIFFERENT WIDE RECEIVERS BUT I
THINK EVERYBODY GETS THE POINT
THIS LIONS OFFENSE NEEDS
WEAPONS.
>> YEAH.
I DIG IT.
LET'S GO -- WHO DO WE HAVE NEXT?
THE BEARS.
>> THE BEARS.
>> GOING WITH THE BEARS.
I'M GOING NICK BONITO, OKLAHOMA.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE BEARS, THEY
HAVE TO PROTECT JUSTIN FIELDS.
SOME OF THE BEST PROTECTION YOU
CAN OFFER IS GETTING THE BALL
BACK FOR EXTRA CHANCES.
HOW DO YOU GET YOUR QUARTERBACK
MORE REPS?
FORCING A FUMBLE.
GET THE BALL BACK TO THE
OFFENSE.
HOW DO YOU GET YOUR QUARTERBACK
REPS?
GET THE STOP ON THE THIRD DOWN.
I THINK THAT'S A PLUS.
THIS IS A GUY -- I MENTIONED
D.J. MOORE WITH DAVID BELL, HE
MIGHT HAVE SOME OF THAT.
TWO MARYLAND GUYS.
MIGHT HAVE SOME OF THAT
CAPABILITY OF COMING ON TO THE
SCENE, BEING AN IMMEDIATE HELP
AS A PASS RUSH SPECIALIST AND
THEN GROWING INTO AN NFL ROLE.
HONESTLY, EVEN WHEN WE DID
REHEARSAL I DID NOT THINK ABOUT
THE MARYLAND TO MARYLAND.
YES, TWO MARYLAND GUYS I'M
COMPARING MY GUYS TO.
>> YEAH.
WITH BONITO, YOU LOVE HE'S A
TRUE STAND UP SPEED RUSHER THAT
CAN THREATEN OFF THE EDGE.
THEY HAVE KHALIL MACK AND QUINN,
TWO GUYS NOT GETTING YOUNGER.
YOU HAVE TO START THINKING NOW.
HE CAN COME IN AND HOLD DOWN A
DESIGNATED PASS RUSH ROLE ON
THIRD DOWNS.
ANOTHER WAY TO HELP JUSTIN
FIELDS CREATE THOSE SHORT
FIELDS, GET THE BALL BACK IN THE
OFFENSE'S ENDS.
I'LL GO WITH TYLER SMITH FROM
TULSA.
THE HULKING DOORFRAME WIDE
OFFENSIVE TACKLE ON THIS TULSA
OFFENSIVE LINE.
HE HAS THE BARE STRENGTH, THE
HANDS THAT CAN DRIVE YOU DOWN
THE FIELD IN THE RUN GAME.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE BEARS NEED TO DO WITH DAVID
MONTGOMERY, THEY NEED TO DEVELOP
THAT POWER RUNNING GAME.
TYLER SMITH, IT'S INTERESTING TO
SEE WHERE HIS LONG-TERM HOME IS
GOING TO BE.
IS IT GOING TO BE LEFT TACKLE?
IS IT GOING TO BE RIGHT TACKLE?
IF YOU NEED SOMEBODY TO COME IN
AND DEVELOP A RUN-HEAVY OFFENSE
THAT HELPS YOUR QUARTERBACK,
THIS IS THE GUY TO DO IT AT THE
RANGE THEY'RE IN IN THE SECOND
ROUND.
ROLLING WITH TYLER SMITH.
LET'S KEEP THIS GOING.
WE STILL HAVE THE VIKINGS AND
PACKERS LEFT.
VIKINGS NEED CORNERS.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
I'LL KICK THINGS OFF HERE WITH
KYLER GORDON IN ROUND TWO.
A LONG, LEAN PLAYER WITH
RECOVERY SPEED.
HE HAS BALL SKILLS, YOU CAN SEE
HIM PLAYIN' THE  ON THE INSIDE.
I LIKE THE LENGTH.
HE IS ONLY GETTING BETTER AT THE
NFL LEVEL.
THAT BODY TYPE LIKE ANTONIO
CROMARTIE, HAS THE COPS TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THERE ON THE
INTERCEPTION ON THE FOOTBALL.
EVEN HIS TEAMMATE, TRENT
McDUFFY, GORDON IN HIS OWN RIGHT
CAN COME IN, START FOR THE BEARS
AND HELP THEM OUT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN GORDON, WHAT
DIRECTION ARE YOU GOING FOR THIS
TEAM?
>> THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT
THINGS.
LOVE THAT YOU MENTIONED THE
CROMARTIE COMP.
LITTLE KNOWN FACT, MY FIRST YEAR
OF COLLEGE, MY FIRST GAME, I WAS
ANTONIO CROMARTIE ON SCOUT TEAM
AT USC, THEY SAID PLAY MAN
COVERAGE, DO WHATEVER.
OKAY.
LOOKING AT THE CARD IT SAYS
ZONE.
THEY WERE LIKE JUST PLAY MAN.
THAT'S ALL HE DOES.
PLAYS MAN ALL THE TIME.
THE COOL THING ABOUT GORDON
COMPARED TO CROMARTIE, HE CAN DO
MORE THAN JUST MAN.
HE IS A GUY THAT -- THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A GREAT SEASON AT
WASHINGTON, WHAT THEY DO HAVE
ARE WELL-TAUGHT DEFENSIVE BACKS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT DID NOT GO
AWAY WITH THE COACHING CHANGE.
THEY STILL HAVE WELL TAUGHT
DEFENSIVE BACKS.
SO HE CAN FIT INTO MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS AND BE GOOD AT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
THE LENGTH IS INCREDIBLE.
BEING ABLE TO PLAY INSIDE VERSUS
OUTSIDE.
ALL THOSE THINGS WE SAW ON TAPE.
I LOVE ALL OF THEM.
STICKING CORNER.
I'LL GO TO PICK 77, A GUY I KNOW
YOU HAVE RANKED IN THIS RANGE.
I WILL GO WITH TYRIQUE
CASTRO-FIELDS FROM PENN STATE,
ANOTHER GUY WHO IS WILLING TO
TACKLE.
AND I THINK THE BIGGEST THING,
HE'S ABLE TO MINIMIZE WHAT
HAPPENS IN FRONT OF HIM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LET HIM PLAY
IN THAT ZONE COVERAGE.
>> WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
VALUE, CASTRO-FIELDS HAD A GREAT
CAREER AT PENN STATE AND HE
LIMITS BIG PLAYS.
A BIG BONUS OF HAVING FELDER
HERE AMONGST MANY, YOU WILL NOT
FIND BETTER DB BREAKDOWNS FOR
THE DRAFT.
WE'LL HAVE FUN WITH THOSE.
YOU'LL KNOW 15 CORNERS AT A
MINIMUM BY THE END OF THIS SHOW.
CLOSING IT OUT WITH THE PACKERS.
WE DO NOT KNOW IF AARON RODGERS
WILL BE THERE, WE DO KNOW
WHETHER IT'S HIM OR JORDAN LOVE,
THIS OFFENSE NEEDS MORE.
WHETHER HE DID VONTAE ADAMS IS
THERE OR ISN'T BECAUSE OF FREE
AGENCY, I THINK HE'LL STAY.
FELDER, WHO DO YOU LIKE AT GREEN
BAY?
>> AT 59, JADEN WIDERMEYER.
HE CAN STAND UP AND BE FLEXED
OUT.
USE THAT WIDE BODY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THOSE
GUYS LEARN REALLY QUICKLY.
HE'S NOT A RECEIVER.
HE'S WEARING 85, BUT HE'S NOT A
RECEIVER.
HE WILL BE HARD TO TACKLE.
I THINK THAT TOUGHNESS TO TACKLE
ADDS TO HIS VERSATILITY.
HE CAN BLOCK IN LINE.
HE CAN CONTINUE TO GET BETTER AT
BLOCKING BUT HE CAN BLOCK IN
LINE.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO CATCH IN
THE SCREEN GAME, VERTICALLY DOWN
THE FIELD.
HE CAN CHALLENGE YOU IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS.
HE WOULD BE A GREAT ADDITION
WHETHER IT'S RODGERS OR LOVE,
HE'S A GREAT ADDITION.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TIGHT END,
TOO.
IF YOU'RE NOT TAKING MY GUY, WHO
ARE YOU TAKING?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO PAIR THEM
TOGETHER.
IF THEY CAN BRING BACK TUNIAN,
IT'S GREG DULCICH FROM UCLA.
YOU WILL SEE HIM IN LINE THERE.
THE NAME OF HIS GAME IS TO MAKE
AN IMPACT AS A MISMATCH
RECEIVING WEAPON FROM THE TIGHT
END POSITION.
YOU CAN GET HIM IN ROUND THREE,
I THINK, IN THIS DRAFT BECAUSE
OF HOW DEEP THIS TIGHT END CLASS
IS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT GREEN BAY
DOES, HE HAS THE CATCH RADIUS IN
THE RED ZONE, THE RUN AND CATCH
BE AB
ABILITY AND HE CAN STRETCH THE
FIELD UP THE SEAM AS IN MIDDLE
OF THE FIELD INTERMEDIATE
TARGET.
THAT 15-YARD KIND OF RANGE.
YOU LOVE THE EXPLOSIVE NATURE OF
THAT SIZE AFTER THE CATCH AND TO
MAKE SOMEONE MISS.
FELDER, YOU WENT WITH
WEIDERMEYER WHO FITS GREEN BAY'S
OFFENSE LIKE A GLOVE.
YOU WILL BE ASKED TO BLOCK AND
DO EVERYTHING.
I GO WITH DULCICH WHO IS MAYBE A
ONE-TRICK PONY RIGHT NOW BUT HE
CAN DEVELOP.
I LOVE THE TIGHT END HELP WE GOT
IN GREEN BAY.
>> LISTEN, IF YOUR ONE TRICK IS
REALLY GOOD, YOU'RE A GREAT
PONY.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING FOR HIM.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM PAIRED
TOGETHER.
WE MENTIONED JORDAN DAVIS.
YOU THINK ABOUT GREEN BAY
RUNNING OUT A 12 PERSONNEL
PACKAGE, THOSE TWO TIGHT ENDS
HAPPEN TO BE THOSE TWO, OH, NO,
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
WE PUT IN OUR BASE PEOPLE, WE
HAVE THREE LINEBACKERS TRYING TO
COVER THESE GUYS.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
IT'S COOL TO WATCH.
I LOVE DULCICH.
WHOEVER PICKS HIM, PUT IN THOSE
CLEAR-OUTS WHERE YOU TAKE OFF TO
A POST AND SNEAK HIM IN BEHIND
OUT OF THAT TRIPS OR OUT OF THAT
WING SHOT SO HE CAN CATCH AS YOU
MENTIONED THAT INTERMEDIATE
ROUTE AT 15 TO 17.
THEN YOU HAVE A PROBLEM AS WE
SAW ON THAT TAPE.
DOWN THE FIELD AGAINST THE
SAFETY AND CORNER, HE'S NOT EASY
TO TACKLE EITHER.
HE'S STILL A BIG BOY.
A LOT OF FOLKS THINK, YOU KNOW,
HE'S A PASS CATCHING TIGHT END.
HE WILL GO DOWN EASY.
NO.
THOSE GUYS STILL LIFT WEIGHTS
WITH LINEBACKERS.
THEY'RE STRONG.
THEY'RE VERY STRONG.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S RECAP WHAT WE DID TO HELP
THE NFC NORTH.
AN EARLY PREVIEW.
THE LIONS THERE, WE EXPECT
HUTCHINSON WITH THE SECOND
OVERALL PICK.
SOME KIND OF ADDITION OF DAVID
BELL AND SKY MOORE.
THE BEARS, OFFENSIVE LINE AND
EDGE.
THE VIKINGS, TWO CORNERS FOR
THEM, NOT GOING AT 12 BUT MORE
ON DAY TWO, TYLER GORDON,
TYRIQUE CASTRO-FIELDS AND THE
PACKERS, HOW THEY CAN IMPROVE
THAT TIGHT END ROOM.
JALYN WYDERMEYER AND GREG
DULCICH, WHO TIGHT ENDS THAT
WOULD COMPLIMENT EACH OTHER
QUITE WELL.
BEFORE WE COME OUT OF HERE,
WE'LL READ A COUPLE COMMENTS.
FELDER, I'LL THROW A QUESTION
YOUR WAY.
FIRST ONE FROM MICHAEL, DULCICH
IS A STEAL.
AARON RODGERS TO THE BRONCOS,
LOCK THAT.
THAT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION.
ALONSO SAYS TIGHT END DEPTH IN
THIS CLASS.
I AGREE.
WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT JAKE
FERGUSON, BELINGER, WE'LL HAVE
PLENTY OF THOSE GUYS ON SHOWS
DOWN THE ROAD.
AS PROMISED, ANTHONY THOMPSON
SAID YOU THINK THERE'S A CHANCE
GREAT LAKES LONDON FALLS TO THE
LATE FIRST FOR DETROIT?
THEY'RE PICKING AT 32.
>> THAT WAS ONE WHERE I WAS
LIKE, MAN, I WAS GOING TO ASK
YOU.
DRAKE LONDON, WHERE DOES HE FIT
IN COMPARISON TO PICKETS?
NOW YOU HAVE THIS DISCUSSION OF
DO YOU WANT THE GUY YOU KNOW
VERSUS THE GUY YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE CAN ACTUALLY BE BECAUSE
HE WASN'T ACTUALIZED IN COLLEGE?
LONDON WAS FORCE FED THE
FOOTBALL ESSENTIALLY, SO WE KNOW
WHAT HIS PRODUCTION LOOKS LIKE.
I LOVE HIM.
HE LOOKS GREAT.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO END UP
BEING A FIRST ROUNDER WITH
PICKENS BEING A SECOND ROUND
GUY.
IF DRAKE LONDON GETS PICKED IN
THE FIRST ROUND, HE WON'T LAST
ALL THE WAY TO THE END.
>> I AGREE.
I DON'T THINK HE'LL BE THERE FOR
THEM.
YOU LOOK AT THE BOARD, THE WAY
IT PLAYS OUT.
IF SOMEONE DOESN'T LOVE DRAKE
LONDON IN THE TOP 15, HE'LL GO
THROUGH THE MEDICAL PROCESS AND
THAT, I THINK HE'S FIRST ROUND
BOUND.
OUTSIDE OF THE TOP 15, YOU HAVE
THE CHARGERS, IF THEY LOSE MIKE
WILLIAMS, YOU SLIDE DRAKE LONDON
INTO THAT ROLE.
YOU HAVE THE SAINTS WHO NEED A
WIDE RECEIVER.
NEW ENGLAND LOOKING FOR THAT
CONTESTED CATCH THREAT AT 21.
RAIDERS NEED WIDE RECEIVER AS
WELL.
LONDON AT 32 PROBABLY NOT
HAPPENING, IF YOU WANT TO
PACKAGE 32 AND 34, YOU CAN
ALWAYS GO UP AND GET THEM.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S A WRAP ON THE FIRST
EPISODE OF "CRASH COURSE."
HOW ARE WE FEELING?
THIS IS THE EASY ONE TO GET OUT
OF THE WAY BEFORE WE HAVE SOME
REAL FUN DONE THE ROAD.
>> I'M READY TO GET INTO THE
NITTY GRITTY AND MAKE THE FOLKS
PULL FILM.
WE'LL BE PULLING OUT NAMES.
THIS WILL BE FUN.
>> YEAH.
THEY'LL BE BUSY WITH THOSE B
ROLLS.
WE'LL BE BUSY HERE EVERY
THURSDAY AT 1:00 P.M.
WE'LL BE LIVE IN THE "BLEACHER
REPORT" APP ON "BLEACHER REPORT"
YOUTUBE, DRAFT CRASH COURSE
EVERY SINGLE WEEK UNTIL THE NFL
DRAFT.
WE'LL CATCH YOU NEXT WEEK BEFORE
THE NFL COMBINE.